I think it's quite likely that AI
systems if they ever could be self-aware
and conscious will not be able to do it
unless they have feelings and feelings
will require sensors that can sense the
outside world and the internal state of
the system that's what's developed in us
the homeostatic system we can started
sensing pain and pleasure but beyond
that we sense the world and then those
physical feelings turn into emotional
feelings and I think it's quite likely
that you won't see chat GPT or a static
regurgitation system that can't sense
the world the interesting question is
whether it'll be become an emotional
connection or not